zurück hierbei bild live herzlich
willkommen und es gibt breaking news
direkt aus dem eu-parlament gas und
atomkraft gelten nun als klimafreundlich
ja das europäische parlament hat den weg
freigemacht investitionen in erdgas- und
atomkraft unter bestimmten bedingungen
als nachhaltig einzustufen ja bestimmte
investitionen in die stromerzeugung in
kernkraftwerken und gaskraftwerken
bekommen damit de facto einen öko siegel
der schritt kommt eine offizielle
empfehlung für investitionen in atom-
und gasprojekte gleich darüber müssen
wir sprechen er unser chefreporter peter
tiede hier bei uns im studio herzlich
willkommen was hat diese entscheidung
war zu bedeuten dass 13 uhr 1 und die eu
schenkt uns einen doppelten 1 und 2
doppelte portion für sind also niemals
auseinander dass kernkraft jetzt
umweltfreundliche ist ja da scheiden
sich die geister dran die einen sagen
nein die anderen jahr hat jetzt ein
grünes leben totale klatsche für die
deutsche politik hier weigert man sich
ja die bestehenden atomkraftwerke drei
stück noch einmal drei jahre länger
laufen zu lassen wegen der gaskrise die
wir haben und der energie krise die wir
haben immerhin wird in deutschland ja
sechs prozent des stroms oscars gewonnen
könnte man das gas um neid nun könnte
dann tatsächlich die atomkraftwerke oder
13 prozent ganze sechs prozent aus
atomkraft die könnte man weiter laufen
lassen würde helfen will man nicht also
klatsche für die deutsche politik für
ihr mann will mag die französischen
präsidenten der sich für sein atomkraft
branche eingesetzt hat und dann kommen
wir mal zum gas beim gas wird es richtig
verrückt also russen gas erdgas dies
klimaneutral ist klimafreundlich
oder fracking gras gas aus den usa nicht
man macht also unterschiede zwischen
verschiedenen glasarten jetzt gehen wir
mal die umweltforschung ein die haupt
klimakiller die bei uns so durch die
luft schweben kommen aus der
gasproduktion aus leckagen aus pipelines
von der erdölproduktion wo gas auf
steigt also auf der zugspitze wird das
gemessen und da ist das hauptproblem gas
ist es aber in der eu umweltfreundlich
ist noch ein alter sieg der merkel
regierung jetzt das durchgesetzt damals
die hat ja auch auf russen gas gesetzt
also totaler irrsinn kernkraft die wir
nicht wollen grün russen gas dass er
nicht mehr kriegen und auch nicht mehr
kaufen auch grün kompletter irrsinn
typisch eu
die entscheidung jetzt da wurde ja auch
ganz schön gerungen vorher es gab
richtig richtig streit darum haben wir
sehen das ja auch hier in deutschland
das ist ja angesprochen die diskussion
darüber ob man die drei atomkraftwerke
irgendwie noch am netz lässt um damit zu
überbrücken da kochen ja auch immer
wieder die emotionen hoch was könnte das
jetzt ganz konkret für auswirkungen
haben können da investitionen in
bestimmten bereichen ansteigen und im
bereich wirklich ausgebaut werden oder
ist es doch nur so eine art bürokratie
irrsinn wir werden ja manchmal auch aus
der eu kennen der im prinzip keine
großen auswirkungen auf die wirtschaft
beispielsweise hat also das ist wirklich
blanker planwirtschaft staatliche hier
in dem fall von der eu planwirtschaft
wir kennen das ja aus deutschland statt
zielwerte grenzwert für umwelt sachen
vorzug zu geben schreibt ja deutschland
zum beispiel schon beim pkw die
technologie vor mit der das erreichen
dann soll nämlich das e auto wird
einseitig gefördert da wird in der
förderung so getan als würde es mit
umweltfreundlicher energie jedes auto
vollgetankt werden das ist eine
ideologie da wird gesagt nur die eine
technik darf das sein statt die stadt
den wert vorzugeben und dann der
forschung der entwicklung der industrie
zu überlassen wie man mit welcher
technologie diesen wert denn erreichen
kann bis zum jetzt kommt die eu macht
ein riesen zinnober das ganze ding nennt
sich grüne taxonomie und ist nichts
anderes als ein wegweiser für banken und
für die eu selber wohin doch gelder
fließen alles was diesen grünen stempel
nicht hat alles was als nicht nachhaltig
gilt ist zukünftig abgeschnitten von
finanzierungen da werden ganze
industriezweige ganz so forschungszweige
auch in den ruin getrieben meistens hat
denn zumindest auswirkungen auf die
innerdeutsche diskussion hier die
atomkraftwerke weiter am netz zu halten
jetzt wo man dieses ja diese
entscheidung hat das eu-parlament
anderen denken jetzt auf dem
kernkraftwerk der grünen stempel klebt
ist es natürlich schwieriger zu
begründen war wo man die nicht mehr will
also das ist deutschland jetzt eindeutig
abgestimmt wird durch die eu auf ihrem
offen sonderweg also schwierig wird es
vor allem auch für die grünen weil man
es sicher in der gesamten ampel da noch
nicht so richtig einig peter thiele
vielen herzlichen dank für deinen besuch
und eine analyse hier im studio